the un's atomic energy agency says it's
ready to send a team of experts to the
zaparisia nuclear plant in ukraine in
the coming days but there's no agreement
yet on how to reach the site
president zielenski warned overnight
that the situation at the plant is still
precarious and dangerous the power
station was temporarily knocked off the
grid this week causing regional
blackouts nuclear experts fear that
fighting around the plant risks a
radioactive catastrophe russian forces
took control of the facility in early
march
the risk of a nuclear disaster in europe
has been looming large for weeks
ukraine says it was narrowly avoided on
thursday
if the diesel generators didn't turn on
if after the blackout the automatic
systems and the personnel didn't start
working we would have to face the
consequences of a radiation accident
russia has put ukrainians as well as all
europeans one step away from radiation
disaster catastrophe
there has been growing concern about
fighting near the power plant
on thursday fires visible here on
satellite imagery
knocked out its last external power line
the electricity it supplied was used for
cooling and safety systems at the
nuclear power plant
ukraine has blamed russian forces for
starting the fires
russia says they were sparked by
ukrainian shelling
key residents worry the danger has not
been averted
i think every sane person is afraid now
everyone is afraid knowing our neighbor
knowing what it is capable of we
understand that there can be different
consequences of what is happening there
now
that is why everyone is afraid we are
not worried about blackouts but that the
ecological situation may change
of course everyone is afraid the entire
world is afraid i really want the
situation to become peaceful again
i want inspectors to finally reach the
plant i want the power shortages to be
overcome and additional facilities to be
operational
i want all of us to live in a safe world
inspectors from the u.n nuclear watchdog
are planning to visit the power station
which is held by russian forces
they're waiting to be granted access
dw correspondent matthias berlinga is in
kiev matthias zaparisia nuclear power
station has been reconnected to the grid
but we understand the situation remains
volatile what's the latest
yeah that's what we that's what we are
hearing um the problem is that we don't
really know what uh things look like at
the power plant itself except for some
uh news that reached the ukrainian
atomic energy authority via some people
inside the plant who might contact
people they know uh former uh or their
their superiors who are at the ukrainian
side but we don't have the full picture
what we understand is that things are
quite chaotic in parts of the plant that
a lot of military equipment is stationed
there and that shelling has been going
on for several days even weeks now and
all that this of course
enhances the risk of some accident at
that site
quite chaotic um what are the prospects
of inspectors from the international
atomic energy agency soon getting access
to the plant
well it seems that there has been a
basic agreement on uh them traveling
from ukrainian territory over the front
line to that site but at the moment they
can't go
we are hearing from the ukrainian side
and from the iaea that
and also from the russian side that the
russian side says it's not secure to
travel there yet they haven't agreed on
some security measures yet the
ukrainians are accusing the russians of
delaying this mission
but
when it could happen is something that
we can't foresee right now
the iaea is ready and
we are waiting for them to to go
matisse there's also the question of
energy supplies zaparisia is an
important power of source for ukraine um
what would it mean for the country if it
lost the plant
so this is the biggest power plant in
europe the biggest nuclear power plant
in europe and uh it is a crucial
supplier of ukrainian energy however
ukraine has three more atomic energy
stations and ukraine has been has had an
electricity surplus it has been
exporting electricity the ukrainian grid
is connected to the european grids
so in the case that this power plant
which is also operate already operating
and not at full capacity there are two
reactors out of six uh working right now
um that if these two reactors would be
shut down there would probably would
there would be shortages certainly in
some areas of ukraine those areas that
are supplied by uh this power plant
directly but um there would be
possibilities to import electricity via
these same channels where ukraine has
been exporting energy before
that's uh matthias berlinga many many
thanks
russia has blocked a final declaration
on the un's main nuclear treaty after a
month-long conference on disarmament the
russian delegation criticized the draft
statement as political and unbalanced
the document included a statement of
grave concern about fighting around
ukraine nuclear sites without naming
russia specifically
other nations expressed disappointment
saying that russia was undermining
international peace